in Bokova Zeno's a gratis has arguably
had the best introduction of any
character in episode 129 this man
attacked the diamond kingdom
single-handedly and wiped the floor with
an army of mages including a few of the
shining generals these guys were meant
to be on par with the magic knight
captains from the clover kingdom
meaning the xenos level of power
comfortably surpasses even that he's
also the first character in history to
genuinely make luck afraid like look at
him the guy who's always ready to fight
always ready to throw down he was
genuinely terrified by this man in this
video I'm gonna explain who Zeno is and
his unique magic power without giving
away any spoilers beyond that
information before we get into the
details though make sure to hit that
button as we are still on the road to
100k Zeno is a member of a group known
as the dark triad who were three
siblings that currently rule the Spay
Kingdom up until this point the story of
black clover has focused almost entirely
on events and characters from the clover
Kingdom with a few Diamond Kingdom
appearances here and there but in
reality it is the spade Kingdom that are
the biggest threat to all the other
nations much like aster each member of
the dark triad is possessed by a devil
which gives them an incredible powerup
that effortlessly outmatches
even spirit magic the beauty of devil
possession is that it gives the user an
additional magic attribute on top of
their original one and in xenos case his
original attribute like the one that he
was born with his bone magic we can see
this on his grimoires design there are
like bones in the middle of it and then
axes on either side and this alludes to
the fact that he can create weapons out
of his bones which we see him doing the
manga to cut through something that
should just we've never seen it been cut
through before and it should never have
been cut through but Zeno was able to do
it often he doesn't actually need to use
his grimoire to just go crazy on people
and start you know destroying them with
bones but his signature spell so far is
called eternal fangs which is when bones
of all shapes and sizes come out of his
body and just slice everyone and
everything in the surrounding area these
bones will stab through people all over
their body I mean like through their
torso their legs and then you kind of
just leave them suspended in the air to
bleed out anyone who tries to destroy
these bow
are also in for a rough time as they
regenerate faster than they can be cut
so there's not really an opening for you
to break them because they just
regenerate too fast in the maggot he's
only gone up to around 55 percent of his
devil powers and he was able to do
incredible things so the future is
looking pretty bright for this character
like I said before though he does have a
second magic attribute due to being
possessed by a devil and you know we
haven't got 100% confirmation on what
this is but from what we've seen I would
estimate that it's a form of spatial
magic that lets the user temporarily
trap their target in some kind of other
dimension this isn't a hundred percent
confirmed but judging by the way that
certain things were drawn that is my
interpretation of it so far some other
cool facts about this character is that
his name is officially xenon but in the
English translation it's called Zeno so
that's just what I use because I read
the manga in English but yeah xenon is
his actual name his character profile
states that his age is unknown and that
his favorite thing in the world is just
nothing in particular this plays into
his cold and merciless personality I'm
fairly certain and he smiled once in
this entire series and I was only
because he was about to skewer someone
last thing I have to say about him
before we get into the spoilers is that
I'm 99% sure that he is plain chicken
with white rice for every single meal
with a healthy serving of
room-temperature water of course and if
you dare even mention adding any
condiments I'm fairly certain that he
would kill you
where do I even begin I mean Zeno is so
amazing he single-handedly took down
William Van gence with ease and if we
remember I think it was said in the
first chapter
vengeance is the person canonically
closest to being the next wizard King
and Zeno generally just no DIF Tim look
at this state of vengeance here like
come on Xena give the guy a chance at
least the way he's still so bored and
uninterested even when he's picking off
different members of the best magic
Knight squad in the clover Kingdom it's
just one of the many reasons why he's
just so awesome as a villain also on top
of all of that the fact that he was able
to confidently storm into the Golden
Dawn knowing that he would beat down
literally anyone who stood in his way
that is a level of confidence that I
aspire to reach the biggest surprise to
me so far was that he didn't make sure
you know was dead because you know when
he arrived he pretty much made it his
mission to kill everyone there and make
sure everyone was dead so the fact that
he would attack you know have him in his
palm and leave him alive or on the brink
of death that was obviously very
surprising though I'm grateful he didn't
finish the job when we look at things
from unis perspective
Xena played a massive part in killing
his parents and you know he probably was
the one to actually physically do it as
well and then he took over the Spade
Kingdom which is what you know should
have done and not only that but he
didn't go to the grave Kingdom and
kidnaps you know squad captain murders
half of you knows your friends and
colleagues
I mean guys this is like for nill to
Xena right now in fact no iz5 no because
he could have murdered you know if he
wanted to and he severely wounded him so
yeah this is five-nil to Zeno and you
know was gonna need to pull out
something massive out the bag to get his
revenge that's just my opinion though I
know a few people in the fandom think
that maybe you know should return back
to spay Kingdom and take up his rightful
place as king but if he did that you
know it would break his vow to aster and
that's just not something I think Tabata
would do especially you know this vow
which has been repeated so many times
throughout this series to deviate from
something that was set up from the very
first chapter I think that would be a
really weird move but we'll see we'll
see I doubt you know what goes to the
Spay Kingdom even though they clearly
would rather prefer he comes back
let me know your thoughts down below as
well as how you think the dark tribe can
realistically be defeated peace out